the orange Menace is heading to court
again Donald Trump Landing in Florida
earlier ahead of his Federal appearance
in Miami set for tomorrow he'll be
arraigned informally charged with 37
Federal accounts for allegedly
mishandling classified documents Trump
wasting no time hitting back
they're not coming after me they're
coming
[Applause]
and baseless indictment of Me by the
Biden administration's weaponized
Department of Injustice
we'll go down is among the most horrific
abuses of power in the history of our
country this vicious persecution
is a travesty of Justice it's amazing
watching Harold nod along with this
the media is cheering on the indictment
but are also worried that a
trump-appointed judge will crash the
party
she was selected fair and square whether
you like that or not and the reality is
in a case like this the public won't
have confidence whether she acquits or
convicts I haven't had this much fun
reading anything since I Read 50 Shades
of right we're also dealing with a judge
who has been known to uh give favorable
Who was appointed by Trump and who has
been known to give favorable rulings the
most significant evidence in the
indictment because of course I read it
gleefully you've said that Trump is
Nixon on steroids uh how so Nixon uh at
least had some sense of Shame and
Obama's former wingman Eric Holder
thinks democrats should impeach Trump a
third time if he wins
the notion that you could have a trial
um defendant be convicted somehow when
the election be sworn in as president or
whenever it happens
um that seems inconsistent with our our
notion of of fairness of of the rule of
law uh at that point I would hope that
an impeachment proceeding um might be
considered
um not only considered broad oh can't
get enough of that you can't debate so
let's put people in court you were upset
judge about the way they're painting
this Trump appointed judge care to
elaborate yes I would love to and I
thank you for coming to me first of all
uh wasn't Eric Holder held in contempt
of congress yeah I thought so but this
is this is classic selective prosecution
Trump derangements syndrome on steroids
now let me be real clear on something
they want this judge gone all right the
decision by the judge as to whether or
not she will go is really a personal
decision to her it is a recusal where I
and any other the judge would say I feel
I can't be fair therefore it's my call
now there is something called a
mandatory recusal where they can prove
that there is a financial benefit that
you're possibly a party you're going to
be substantially affected by the outcome
none of that is the case here so guys
deal with it now let's talk about the
fact that who is on the southern
district bench in Miami in Florida so
you've got five Trump appoint to judge
and you've got seven Clinton Obama
judges so let's just face it they want a
Clinton Obama judge and not a trump
appointed judge those are their options
and that's the end of that now let's
talk about the fact that how she was
chosen there's a wheel it's the case in
every federal court they have a wheel
they pull a name out of the Hat it's
that simple the fact that she made a
real ruling on Trump's behalf in another
case is irrelevant all right so let's
talk about what we've got here we've got
a case that is not only going to impact
um you know the the prosecution it will
show the political nature of this
prosecutor Smith they want to get rid of
the judge I think we should get rid of
the prosecutor Smith Smith is a guy who
has been rejected by the Supreme Court
in an 8-0 decision uh that I talked
about before in his prosecution over
reaching prosecution of a governor in
Maryland and the the Edwards case where
a jury rejected his uh political stances
so he's unethical Beyond in terms of the
Court's response to him and jury's
responses to him judges have turned
against him and courts have turned
against him and let me make one more
thing clear he is a special counsel he
is not a special prosecutor therefore
everything he does has to be approved by
Merrick Garland he works under Merrick
Garland and finally let me say why are
they so afraid of this guy there is no
evidence that Trump destroyed or gave
away classified information and I'm not
going to spend a lot of time I'm on
Hillary we know that James Comer James
Comey said that her evidence was hacked
by others countries tune in anything
else well not a ton I think that
um there's two things too but there's a
legal defense which we will finally
learn more about tomorrow after he
appears and then there's the political
defense we know what the political
defense is and president Trump is not
shy about it he's talked about it all
weekend he is getting other Republicans
to defend him and he he's just basically
going going to go full bore and he'll
give his statement tomorrow what's very
interesting at this point and Sean
Hannity asked Governor Gavin Newsom
about Governor
is the issue for example of homelessness
Crime Liberty education and there you
talked about how 80 of people want to
have a debate they want to have a debate
about like those big issues but this
issue just because you can prosecute
should you prosecute but that's also
water under the bridge too because now
it's actually happening
um previous people who've been in this
position have pled down to a misdemeanor
and moved on I
seriously doubt that will happen
tomorrow
um so we'll just have to wait and see
and then he was going to speak to the
nation after that so Harold you said uh
during the break this is much to do
about nothing I can't believe that they
would try to Target a beloved folk hero
that has changed so many lives
care to elaborate on that what you said
and you're going to deny it slightly
different records I have the tape right
here so so I'd say a couple things I
agree with the judge in one regard the
judge is fit to serve down there yeah uh
this judge here and if she proves that
she's not then I'm sure the parties
there will will say otherwise too I
differ with the judge when we talk about
this judge here when we talk about
judges because I think we're reaching a
dangerous point in the country where we
think if you're a Democrat the only way
you can have a fair trial or be treated
fairly in a courtroom is if the judge uh
is appointed by Democrat and vice versa
in each the other side I think I think
that I think I don't know if you meant
to make that point but I think that some
are making this point a lot
what I can't figure out
um and I hear the comparisons with
Hillary Clinton and and Bill Clinton and
others and I watch Bill Barr this
weekend on on Sunday who's been a great
defender of the presidents but was not a
Defender president Trump on Sunday
the difference I think between the cases
with the clintons and everyone else when
when President Trump was asked on one or
two occasions to return these documents
he chose not to now he claims I think
what's going to the legal predicate of
this case is that President Trump
believes that he's entitled to these
documents because they're governed under
the presidential records act and Mr
Smith who if he's a bad lawyer then if
he was if he indicted me I'd want him
because that means we can beat him but
if he's a bad lawyer he believes or
should say his theory of the case is
that this has to be a notch thing but at
the root of it had the president I think
president Trump just returned the
documents after they asked him the third
time
we wouldn't be facing this and he I
don't wish it's on him I think people
saying that things that they're saying
they enjoyed the re I never enjoy to
read about anyone being indicted unless
they've killed somebody and don't get me
wrong what the president what he's
accused of is bad but I don't I don't
like I don't pile on people like that I
get people who do but I don't do that
but I hope the president answers the
question in the courtroom when he when
he finally gets before the 12 jurors why
didn't you return the papers when you
were asked to well shifting through them
and determining what we're personal and
what were presidential and under the
presidential records as you know Harold
he has the sole discretion to do that
even when he showed it to that reporter
well if you're waving it to that
reporter who's an American how is that
different than Hillary's server getting
hacked by the DNC server getting hacked
the Obama Administration getting act he
put American National Security at risk
because he went like that in front of an
American meanwhile we'll see Joe Biden
spread eagle all over the Mid-Atlantic
and Chinatown he's got his garage wide
open well Hunter's flying in with drunk
Chinese spies come on Espionage Act
president
he didn't even start a single War he
wiped Isis off the map he put National
Security risk Espionage Chinese are
lining the Biden family Pockets Carol
Ford Jr better than that this is death
by accusation first he's a colluding
Trader then he's a rapist and then he's
a Nazi and now he's throwing papers all
over the Middle East for cash they'll
put him on trial they'll leak they'll
smear they don't even care how this
thing is adjudicated it doesn't matter
they're scaring away donors and swing
voters Republicans need to get their act
together and they better circle the
wagons if he had cocaine in those boxes
that were stacked up in the ballroom
then maybe if he's running a cocaine
ring out of Mar-A-Lago maybe they don't
Circle Joe could send Hunter to check
that out exactly but he's not this is
about remember Allen Iverson we're
talking about practice
we're talking about a piece of paper a
military member we're talking about a
piece of paper Harold Ford Jr Biden gets
caught red-handed with Chinese bribes
nine members of his family but you know
what the Democrats do they circle the
wagons they redefine what a bribe is you
can bribe an entire family with cash
diamonds and gifts but if it doesn't hit
Joe's bank account it's not a bribe come
on Harold Ford Jr he's treated like an
enemy combatant they take away
attorney-client privilege
and then they're upset because people
might get upset in Miami yeah people are
upset I like the fact that he's
promising to appoint a special counsel
and sic'em on Biden if he's elected why
do you think can he keep a lawyer why do
all the lawyers keep resigning well
that's a good question but we gotta go
to Brick yeah yeah well I think you
learned something here Harold Ford Jr
yes nothing you learn nothing here I
wonder Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now